what are you most proud of and your
playing career I'm most proud of my
outstanding free-throw percentage if
you're over here make one excellence one
day it won't be recognized and then will
be remembered because you are different
so master being different mother always
told me make him remember your nation no
matter how many million a he's a retired
professional basketball player he was
drafted by the Orlando Magic and quickly
became one of the best centers in the
NBA he is currently an analyst on the TV
program inside the NBA the Shaquille
O'Neal and here's my take on his top ten
rules of success rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
hopeful surrender to other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
you as well enjoy
what is it about investment in
entrepreneurship that sort of has bitten
you I never look at it as investments
believe it or not I just look at it as
partnerships help changing the world and
just being part of something that's
inspiring my business people out of town
whenever they talk about money you guys
do my job
I don't want to hear it but if they
bring an idea to be I think is going to
go to the next level
most of the time if I follow my heart
and everything else will fall in place
I've never ever done a deal a we got
this new company we throw some
pinstripes in the student he gave me out
of thousand we still are 2001 we make
I've never did a deal where it was
always based on money
I've always did my bidding skills based
on how I felt it was going to go in the
future our Father was going to help and
inspire somebody
[Music]
four points one
what are you most proud of and your
playing career I'm most proud of my
outstanding free-throw percentage 51
percent next one this one no I almost
almost proud that I've made it so to
just fulfill the dreams and just work
hard and you know just persevere through
everything and you know I learned that
at age 13 14 15 to use criticism as
motivation so whenever somebody told me
I couldn't do it it just made me go and
work harder
plus you've got a big case on
Fieldy crabs he doesn't go back it up
and
terracing exact investments not going to
always go how you want me to go business
plan is not going to go how you want
them to go so you just have to just have
to regroup you know you can never if
they regroup what does that mean what is
that right my theory my thought process
is to never focus on the problem focus
on the solution I invested in this water
company it didn't go well that money is
gone now I've got to regroup now I got
to do something else so I'll be upset
for about 20 minutes go to that cabinet
get them frosted flakes get some of that
cold milk sliced them bananas up
watching ESPN and then the next day I'm
back on truck y'all got that that's
pretty good but the key thing event
focus on the solution not on the problem
because where your energy goes as where
your focus and concentration goes
Oh
haha morning
he went for
anyplace
and the one thing I tried to do was when
I came in was wanted to be different you
know my dad you know growing up I
realized that I was a little bit
different but but I didn't like being
different and he would tell me you know
what one day you're gonna be recognized
and then will be remembered because you
are different
so master being different don't be like
everybody else master being different
right falling away won't go for the
final shot ten more take them
that's my theory there because we he
came down in for another quick shot
don't do it because you trying to get
your followers up Donna may like if
you're not really with the cause you're
not going to dedicate yourself a
thousand percent don't do it
could you talk about Jim Brown and there
was those guys they dedicated themselves
a thousand percent we didn't have
twitter back then and you follow an all
day dedicated itself a thousand percent
so we're not gonna dedicate yourself a
thousand percent if you're not going to
do it when the cameras are off don't do
it
but Dave Robson was the nicest man ever
I was about to big man on campus in San
Antonio then the Spurs they draft him
and he steals all my shot so I'll be the
one day those I miss Ruxin can I have
your autograph so ever laughing I learn
as a big man you could you can get easy
buckets by running the floor also learn
to spin a lot of things learn doesn't
watching David Rosen so I meet him we
have a conversation she sighs ma de
Graaff first how he plays the Spurs he
kills me kills my father written in
Illinois you show too much respect I
don't care this day Rosen shackling me
to dominate you Goldman think about what
you need to do if I was like you know
what
he didn't give his autograph in Austria
two years old that pisses me out so like
from that point on when I said that to
myself that he didn't give me out he
stiffed me for autograph as a youngster
I wanted to pay him back browse my way
of competing with day rocks
[Applause]
probably after the event
[Music]
there are so I guess we will never know
he's going to do it something I did you
destroyed the bathroom last games that a
SOT we're starting schools with
something off the bed
almost down
[Applause]
you have any advice for people looking
to kind of branch out of their comfort
zone you have to you know to you know to
value partnerships like I've always been
a basketball player I've always played
basketball I would I could probably say
I'm a master of basketball so now what I
wanted to become a businessman like I
have to go through the do's and don'ts
of business but you know to get respect
as a business mouse let me go ahead get
this Masters in Business Administration
so they know and understand what I'm
talking about you know I've always
considered myself a leader so you know
my thought process is let me get this
doctorate in leadership so people will
know and understand and my thought
process on how I do things but I've
always been smart enough to have people
better than me on my team for example
like books limiters TechCrunch so for
mastaba
magazine so if I almost all the magazine
called TechCrunch let's believe amount
of the techies publisher my detectives
camera guys and I was a techies
interviewers working for me rather than
me trying to do everything by myself so
you have to you know value you know
partnership for example if I want to be
the best sheriff in Austin Texas I got
to get the best police officers I can't
okay I can't be the best without having
the best team so I've always I've always
I've always always value partnerships
and I always have people better than me
and smarter me around me so they can
motivate me so they can help me
[Applause]
Wow that's you yes how old are you 16
growing up a military brat he frequently
changed schools and had to make new
friends he struggled to feel comfortable
in his own skin
I'll always thrived on uniqueness my
mother always told me make them remember
your nation no matter how making me no
DNA well guess it pays to listen to mom
[Music]
Jack oldest Kyle puts up a three he
missed it and Turner chases it down
Sacre - overall I show ha ho favorite
yes
my goodness I don't want to be
remembered as a as a athlete who made a
lot of money or an athlete who did great
movies like Kazaam I know what blue
chips I don't I don't want to be
remembered for a guy that's won a lot of
championships I want to be remembered as
a guy because of his actions he inspired
people to learn more to do more into one
more
[Applause]
[Music]
Buie follow me
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
haha look back in mourning
oh he came flying out of nowhere
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Philip Dubois
skee asked me to also if you want to
nominate someone for the next top 10
video please check the description for a
link to a video where you can vote for
people and put in your suggestions as
well I'd love to know what did you take
from this video what was the most
important lesson that you learned that
blew your mind that you're going to
immediately apply to your life or your
business somehow please leave it down
the comments below I'm super curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jude Q thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and taking that picture it's
amazing to see thank you so much again I
appreciate the support and I hope you're
enjoying the read so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
and you know Rev I rather than Dale
Brown a similar guy at state aid teach
never give up you know I can remember
again we we want to play a well and Pat
Riley comes in you guys mine art art in
it he comes in with a big bucket of
water it's all up here you could do
anything you want I'm putting my head in
that bucket for three minutes later I
still in one year the records of men in
30 like people to go scuba diving
military and maybe two and he did it for
30 minutes oh come on three minutes
early especially as collectors did these
papers here yes Iran yes yes you start
always part of that is more amazing I'm
telling he did it
so I guys like looking at my you know
what she's right so like here's just
features and just stories and you know I
always tell people that's what always
took me to the next level not trying it
not going out and being in the gym three
house conversations so those kind of
things whether it's Sarge or whether
it's Dale Brown or Phil and then four or
Pat Riley those were the kind of things
that gave you that that you needed yes
because growing up it took a
disciplinarian to make new life
I took a disciplinarian for me to stop
being a follower allowed to be really
nice house a medium level juvenile
delinquent I used to come home and get
in trouble my father let you said just
I'll be in the follow of that I know
your friends wanted to steal the car you
jumped in the car with them and
everybody is in trouble just after you
learn how to be a leader tell me this do
you feel any pressure because people say
there's now Shaq is in LA we're going to
a championship right away I know that
you probably came here to try and win a
championship but do you feel like all
the pressures on you to come win one I
really don't believe in pressure my job
is to just go out play well you know you
have to realize that all the
expectations that said on me those are
the same expectation that I set for
myself
I just wanna come over one never give up
work hard and continue to learn not only
do I talk to talk I try and walk the
walk on FLS you in 1992 2000 I received
my bachelor's I'm the mom says she was
on whoopee
[Music]
mama had alter ego to it and the name
was bigger bill 2004 I received my MBA
[Applause]
2012 I received my doctorate in
education
[Applause]